they would have seen me weeping  multiple times throughout the movie  throughout the elvis movie throughout  the elvis movie when the end of this  thing hit  i was crying so much that when the  lights came on for the credits i ran  like i had to go to the bathroom it was  [ __ ] i had to go into the bathroom  and finish crying because i didn't want  my parents to see me crying  because i was so embarrassed  i came out of the bathroom  i'm trying to like make my eyes not look  red my mom was like oh my god i loved it  so much the ending i almost started  crying again i walk away  for two days after i got back  so it was so emotional i'm gonna ruin  the ending for you you gotta see it okay  well i know he does  you foolish child  you foolish cheap joke foolish hearts  you just  you don't deserve to hear the ending of  this movie